私は
獣医学もなんで重視になりますコーナーで
マートであっていま戦後はフォースラン
いう領域を大学で教えています
つの中でいろいろなことを考えています
補正案というのは社会で偽さを変えている方
例えば寝台障害の障害を与えているんじゃないか
高齢者
人にはそういう方々に馬というものに出会っていただいて馬と一緒に活動をしてその中
で社会でできる方向を見つけている伴う社会で参拝するきっかけを作るそんなあ
プログラムを作っています
シャーカーンさんするというのは一つレイヨンエ here から者海域品自分の場所
つけていくかということを考え
そんな母数選びを今行っています
遊びを普及するために良いと大学で教えからいろんなところで事業所をつくったりして
きましたけども
アルルカン万実ねあの硬いに自分直しましたがどういうことかというと
社会でいない難しさを抱えている人たちが
ポスターメディアできるきっかけを行う
そこまでは
うまくいって車間にいそうな人たちがいるんですけれども結局
車間居場所がなかった
また戻ってきてしまうということを研究しました
すなわち発作機をやるためにはモンスターフィールド
だけを人じゃなくてその後のことを考えていかなくてはいけないそういうことに気が
つきました
ちなみお話をするの服連携話につながっていくん
社会できるましょうチャットどの人も誰もが
者海域だレベルはけどその後は皆さん
生きやすい社会になるのである
そんな風に考えているんです
社会にいる
どうかことなら社会に史上最大で動画もらうかなと考えると
まずはなるのが社会で活躍できる場所があると
大活躍できなくても必要とされるそういうことは大切なんでもないから
という風に考えました
すなわち居場所とか意外
それぞれ皆さんやなるはずですけれどもそれを自分たちで見つけにくい人たち
その一弦に来る人たちにはそういうことを一緒に共に入っ
出来ることは何からことを見つけていくそんなことが必要なのかな
そこでそういう行き元居場所ということを見つけるのを少し
発現させたところで納付クレイていうものにやりました
私次頑張ってのところで a
チョコあげているということもありますけどもいろんなであるようなら
のフレイというものを歯が始まっているそれを押します
簡単8往復連携は農業と福祉それぞれ持つ課題
お互いを見ないと女がことによって
配列していくとを目指すます
農業守った片山持っているかと
3つあります
1つ目はまず農業生産人で農業に従事している人たちの平均方々の現金ででが非常に
書くな
60歳を超えてしまう
そーゆーめーじ
二つ目は
[音楽]
安く農業やろういう人たちが少ないん
新規就農者が減っているすなわちっ子受けさんはちょっと見なくっ
ということがあるん
3つ目はそういう人手不足もあるんですけれども日本では耕作放棄地が増えていっ
だからなぁ
ただでそう来なくっ
もう作物を作ろうと思っても救う力でなくそんな状況があります
一方福祉の課題はどんなものがあるかというと
一つ目は
働けなくてもとなってないん
という言葉があります
いわゆる生産年齢人口にあるのか
なんか15歳から65歳未満の方ねいただきたいという手段っていうのを働けてない方
が150万人を超えることが日本は全国にいらっしゃいます
その方は働きたいなら働けない非常に寂しい思いました
そしてもうひとつは
そういう人たちが働けても働ける場所が少なくて
実際では事業所ぞ
そういうところで打たれるわけですけれどもまあ
月額の毎月の平均工賃がー
15,000円たーーー
毎日ではなくて月の平均コーチが一番保全だ
彼らは自立しようにも犬の多い状況にあります
そういう形を変えるために第二産業農業漁業
畜産のそういうところでいろいろな連携の試みがあっという方があるんし
いろんなねぇありますけれどもさらにの方まで行けるもない店ということで私自身は
新しい
のフレイ稽古てるを作れるそういうチャンスに出会うことか
たまだまだ役の一緒に仕事をして仲間か
昆虫の専門で介護の専門誌
ハイガーにオムニ
4使っていう
用制御です
要するによわぁ
明治1個日本の一第二さんでした
6よ産業を使って
高齢所
背後の筆は障害が垂れるん
そういう人たちが自立に向けたことを社会参加できないからと考えたわけです
まあすごいのはネーミングが室
は perele
ま8 the というものと可能
介護どっか行こう忍者いますね地下も訪問介護という授業の中でやろうということで先
に訪問か行こうっていう名称が神上がりました
この本会の新しい納付ブレーキのモデルとしていけないだ
ん
ただで妄想しただけではそれを土産につなげて
事実まで手助けをすることほどともに現場がいいんです
それを変えるためにいろんなことはチャンスなりました
いやー
ある特別な原酒の会合というものがある
昨日介護は
4段戦です日焼けの原因語る市街作用
下げるよう予防を使う
この海を糸にするわけだよな
話して化粧品に使う
サザンアイディアが医学書仲間と生まれてきます
首相に入れねー
違うじゃチェーンすることができるということになれば石油製品に由来しない
日焼け止めの
化粧品
いろんなねーずがあるそうだなということになります
その日やけ止めの原料になる入った
破格買ってくれる化粧品会社も出てきました
昨日お前を超えていっ
太鼓というのは25日もあれば浜ばからあまりになります
1月に入り1オナする5万円さん
すぐそれは彼らを社会に生きにくさを抱えて仕事場な人にとってもできることがあり
ます
またそれには開港前13を挙げなくている
はをとってきてキビの生活を充実させ
介護という疑問おそらくそれを前に曽我
仕上げその前もきれいしぜひます
社会に必要とされるそういう社会に活躍できるましょう
作れるのがこれを訪問がいる
というふうに思います
そしてそれは何かというと彼らができることになってもらうです
できないことができていいなぁ
そんな社会で切るのに苦労しないわけですけれども
できないことがいっぱいあるホラー
難しい理由だっ
つのできないことをできることできないことをできるようにするのではなくてその人に
できることをもっとできるようなあるいはできることを仕事にできればえん
例えばああ私なんかあんまり長続きしない
楽しいなんていうことを
1日中放棄強く経年できる能力を持った人たちがあります
そういう人たちが葉が集まって一つの例ですが
とチリの方ではブドウ畑
ぶどうを完了します
家たくさん踊ったりブドウの実に袋をかけそのことをして結果としてオーバーに黒く道
をつく
その運動を使って1位だその場合をモバイルを販売し
サミットで使われたります
またワインですからちゃんと商売
福知らない障害者の方が主張ガンたーれた方が作った
マイナー
うえねー税金が収められる
そんなことができないだろういう風に考え
葉酸というものにはのにいろんなことができるなと思う
中間それを大き始まる動かせ始めます
ただ43だけだと問題と思います
ローさんクローラーを食べるんで使い方がいます
カーラーは夏しかっ
冬のマイナー何か仕事を作らないん
僕たちは自分で仕事を見つけてくることができますけれどもいろんな役に草が生えてき
た仕事を見つけることも難しい人たちが少なくありません
冬の間の仕事を半から他馬の中で街というものを思いつきます
実はワシワシの原料は
構造ですけれども後続馬っていうのは非常に近い関係ないです
その構造トークは近い関係から来はわずか8パー会とか食べるけどその機能木
archi 能見気を使ってそこから橋を作れないかなーっていうことをやれるしてい
ました
監視をしていますか
炭の間の仕事として所これをまた
できた完了
いろんな所で使ってもらう製品のラベル使ってもらう
そこでも売り上げが挙げられるかだ
そういうことで
農副連携ということを予算始めた場所はで手を出すこという
でも全部はなく仕事をつくることになります
star
お気づきのように
もしなければいい
そのものが車ばだけます
どうぞ
それは農副連携の農協の人さん
今作ごきチャを使わないということになりました
地域にいろいろお話をして耕作放棄地 day
美しい施設の方に配合してもらえるからーっ
グアバだけを作るそこから黒那覇をとってきて背後にあるん
残ったような和紙です
一つの循環ができまたいろんな福祉の両院が地域に出てるきっかけになります
また地域は耕作放棄地がいますので地域づくりという過程から協力を安く
福祉用の地域と一緒に地域の地域再生地域づくりそんなことまで一緒にできるそんな
ことに気がついて思う
ブーバーしたけども
ブーブーことはだーいろいろなあー代以下女性したよ
という風に思っています
その中ではどんどんの服連携
今日お話をした訪問回答なんていうのは一つの
事例すみませんまだまだ色んな事例を作っ
もしかすると増強というあるいは第1作業というのは私たちが自分自身をに気圧
行きやすくするためのいろんなヒントがあるのではないかという風に考え
今私が取り組んでいるの連携
それだけだと広がるないろんな戻りを作るしもっとほんと位のな人と一緒に仕事をして
未来作っているきっかけを作りたいなと
実は新しいが0
すみません
123135なる農学農業の中でないか
さまざまな新しい事件
本当にいろんな違いがありますけれども実はそれは私たちあまり機械やすい形では
葉酸そうです43は障害者の堀田方ができるという去年な
これなんですけどもまだまだそこまでモデルなができなかったからできていま
まあ一にょろ
デザー c
社会で使いやすいをモデル化していく
そのことをやろう考えられますそれからデザインどわーというものです
こういう概念をそれに作っ多くの人がこの溶液の服連携というものから社会のことを
考え
誰もが生きやすい社会を考えればそんなところにつなげるそういうきっかけの
をつくっていくことができればと思っています
誰もできることはまだまだありますそのできることをどんどん伸ばして一緒に私たち誰
もが住みやすい社会をつくるそんな心の一緒にできればと思っています
dj
ああああああ
[拍手]